- I like Skid Row actually.
It's just kinda like,
it's not, I love skid row.
- You love it?
- Yeah.
- How long you been down here?
- Not long enough,
maybe a month and a half.
- [Mark] Where were
you hanging out before?
- [Rebecca] I was in San
Jose, and then San Francisco.
I used hang out by the beach.
- [Mark] And you're from
New York originally?
- Yeah, New York, yeah.
- [Mark] Were you homeless
in New York as well?
- For a little bit, yeah.
I used to turn Brooklyn, Prospect Heights.
- [Mark] Did you at one point have a job?
- I kinda ran raves for a bit, sort of.
I modeled for like, I
dunno, maybe a few weeks.
- [Mark] What kind of model?
- Fashion, fashion modeling.
- [Mark] As a man or as a woman or?
- As a woman.
- As a woman?
- Yeah
I prefer, you know, I identify as female,
so I wouldn't do any
male modeling personally.
You okay?
- Yeah, I'm great.
So you've been here for a few years,
and do you play around with drugs?
We talked about this briefly last time.
- Yeah, I do drugs.
- What are your favorites?
- I'm doing methamphetamine, cocaine, LSD,
TCB, and cigarettes.
- What's your favorite?
- Fashion.
(Mark laughs)
Cigarettes, cigarettes.
- Cigarettes?
- Cigarettes.
Cigarettes, molly,
meth, cocaine, TCB, LSD.
- [Mark] Cool, and where
do you sleep at night?
What do you do?
- Side of the road, blanket.
- I think I asked you this-
- There, here, anywhere.
When it's time to sleep, just boop.
- [Mark] And do you get hassled at all
just 'cause you're-
- Very fortunate not to,
very fortunate not to.
I try to keep to myself.
I do my thing, I do my
thing, I do my own thing.
Find some people to kick it with,
find some people to kick it with.
I tend to spend most of my time alone,
and it's a shit-ton of fun.
I never really liked being alone,
and you know, being a vagabond
or being a voyager kind of.
Like, I was never really
a wander, you know.
I used to love walking around,
like taking long walks,
but when that's like your entire life,
there's so much pleasure in
it, you know what I mean?
I never thought I could have that.
- [Mark] It's a very
interesting neighborhood, right?
- I love Skid, I fucking love Skid Row.
Skid Row is like probably
like my favorite neighborhood
outside of like, you
know, like Beverly Hills,
like you shouldn't see
kind of thing, you know,
but I'd say Skid Row, Melrose,
Beverly, Santa Monica, Venice.
Venice is like. (laughs)
You ever see that movie, what was it?
You know the second "Valley of the Dolls,"
"Beyond the Valley of the Dolls?"
♪ Come with the gentle people ♪
- Never saw it.
Never saw it.
- You should see it.
Although I think before the first one,
but the second one has these
shots kind of Anez Valda.
Sorry, I'm a real cinephile.
- [Mark] So Rebecca, have
you been in love before?
- Always.
Always. I'm in love right now.
- [Mark] When you say always, I mean.
So did you ever, a significant
relationship, a real-
- In a sense, yeah, in a sense.
- [Mark] And who is that with?
You don't need a name-
- I don't wanna name them.
There's a few people.
There's one man in particular.
I don't know, it's not that I don't
feel comfortable talking about it.
It's like, be more specific,
like love is everything.
I love everything. I love everyone.
A view of this dress, other people I meet.
I fucking love Skid Row.
I love Rachel Zoe.
- [Mark] So you seem happy.
Are you, would you-
- I am very happy.
- [Mark] You would
describe yourself as happy?
- I'm very, very, very-
I never thought I could
live a life like this.
I'm in like in a state of like awe.
- [Mark] Do you ever get down, depressed?
- Yeah, of course. Everyone does.
Used to be really suicidal.
It's okay, you know.
It's fine to feel that way,
but I find a pleasure in it.
It's like I feel more melancholy,
you know, than depressed.
There's a beauty to it.
You know, like people say,
there's an art to living.
There's a beauty-
- [Mark] Yeah, they're different things.
- Like a certain sense of,
there's an ease within it.
Slows you down and kind of.
You're more pensive. You think more.
When everyone's like.
♪ I'm a party girl ♪
- [Mark] Do you get cold at night?
- Sure. Well, I'm actually very lucky.
I always tend run into a jacket
or a blanket at some point.
I got cold, and I start running around,
you know what I mean?
Always running Skid Row.
There's always gonna be
something on the floor, you know?
- [Mark] So during your typical day,
you'll leave Skid Row at some point?
- Yes, of course.
Look, I just walk everywhere
honestly, you know what I mean?
Just always walking around-
- And just sleep wherever?
- Yeah, whenever it reaches me.
I'd rather do drugs than
sleep, you know what I mean?
Eat, sleep, rave, repeat,
hypothetically speaking.
- [Mark] When's the last
time you slept on a bed?
- Four days ago or three days ago?
Yeah, four days ago.
Slept for a week when
I was in the hospital.
- [Mark] You were in
the hospital, for what?
- It was the most boring
thing, for like my ankle.
- [Mark] What happened to your ankle?
- Oh, sorry, my foot is killing me.
Kinda twisted it sort of.
- You twisted it?
- Yeah, but then it got fixed.
- [Mark] Have you had other
hospital visits in the past?
- Yeah, I was in the hospital
briefly for being suicidal.
I'm not ashamed to talk about it.
It's just, you know, it
was a part of things.
Thinking back on it makes me so grateful
for how my days, I'm like,
I spend almost 90% of my
time wanting to be alive.
This was a time in my life
when I had no desire to live.
Everything was like I can't
wait for this to be over,
and I was like, I'm so,
you know what I mean?
There's a thing that (indistinct) said,
she's like, "It's so fucking great.
"You're too spoiled."
Blonde, green and pink. Sorry,
it's from a fashion show.
- [Mark] Tell me about your parents.
- I don't talk about my family.
- [Mark] Last time, you
told me your parents died-
- I don't wanna talk about it.
- You don't?
- [Mark] All right.
- I don't talk about my family.
- [Mark] I won't bring it up.
- Just being honest.
- Understood.
Who are your friends
now? You have friends?
- Sure. Define like close,
like regular friends
that I see around here?
- [Mark] Like friends you've had
for a long period of time.
- Oh yeah, I've had best friends for ages.
Like it's my girl Deebs, Tim.
This girl was Sheels.
- [Mark] I assume you don't have a phone
or anything like that to contact
them or anything like that?
- My bestest friends are called
Halsey ironically enough and
weird, really weird name, Varunshaw.
Halsey and Varunshaw, they're
like my bestest friends.
It's weird little girls, you
know, long hair, don't care.
- [Mark] And they're also
living on the street?
- Yes, they are.
They're just like me.
They love to wander the
streets like a profession.
To hear music, be inspired,
you know, by that.
- [Mark] So this outfit that
you're wearing is beautiful.
- Thank you, it's a piece of fabric
I found under a car somewhere, like.
I can't tell you where, but it was, okay.
It's about maybe a
10-minute walk from where
the Panda Express is by the 99-cent store.
- [Mark] This is just some fabric
you threw together to make that?
- I just found it, and I
keep making things with it.
I wanna find something new honestly,
but I haven't found one yet.
I can shut up. That's all I do all day.
- [Mark] So the drugs
you use, they cost money.
Where do you-
- Sometimes yes, sometimes no.
- [Mark] Where do you make money?
How do you generate money?
- Sometimes I prostitute.
Sometimes, I begged.
My favorite thing is, honestly,
it's like the laziest move of the world.
I sell, but like a drive
through, and it's like a 50-50.
You either got money, or you get food,
and I'm like, hi, can you
spare some money for some food?
Please help me with some food.
Please can I have some food.
It's a good way to work on your-
- [Mark] And people will help you out?
- In a sense. Sometimes yes, sometimes no.
It's a gamble, it's a game.
Life is a game, a game of
will they or won't they.
Eventually, something's gonna
happen, you know what I mean?
Someone's gonna, know
what I mean, okay fag,
just book it, you know what I mean?
Burger has arrived.
- [Mark] Some kind person comes by
and helps you out?
- Yes, yes.
- [Mark] Or some
photographer you stumble on.
- Or a photographer, and I
just happen to turn into a guy
who's very attractive, but you know,
I don't mean that anyway. (speaks faintly)
- [Mark] Where do you see
yourself in five years?
- Working at "W Magazine."
That is my aspiration,
to work at "W Magazine."
- [Mark] Excellent.
Dreams are good to have.
- Dreams are good to have, yes.
Hypothetically speaking though,
at the current rate I'm going,
in a dumpster somewhere
digging around for a dress.
- [Mark] You think that's more likely?
- With a straw up my nose, yep,
singing some kind of a
song about something and-or
looking for my friends Verge and Halsey,
to see what's up with Verge and Halsey.
Just rifling through dumpsters
looking for gowns usually,
but maybe let's look for a
good jacket or something.
(laughing) Yes.
Either one is an ideal of life, I think.
I feel like I have an idealized-
I feel like I have a pretty
cool life, life on the streets.
- [Mark] But what are your favorite
qualities about yourself?
- I don't give a fuck.
I have great fucking taste.
I have so much love within me
that I didn't know that I, you know.
(indistinct) Little chasing people,
and I don't give have a shit, you know.
I do what I do, and then
I'm happy right now.
- [Mark] But what are your
least favorite qualities about yourself?
- I'm lazy.
Sometimes I'm like too
selfless or too empathic.
It's too easy for me to shit on myself,
like I shit on myself a lot, you know.
I don't like, you know what I mean?
Like, I settle too easily.
I don't have any kind
of, I mean like, mmm.
Like sometimes, you know what I mean,
but usually I'm just like, oh, whatever.
Like I wish maybe I would
like more like bitch about it.
I don't know, and I'm too
prone to just giving up.
I give up too easily sometimes, you know.
But it's better to quit
than to, you know, like.
I'd rather quit then
feel bad about winning.
- [Mark] Or losing?
- [Rebecca] Um...
I think I'd rather lose than win
just 'cause it's like fuck it,
I don't want the recognition.
I wanna do what I do,
you know what I mean?
- [Mark] But what do you think
got you down here on the street?
Was it just lack of responsibility,
or is it drugs, or was it-
- Fun!
It's so fucking fun!
It's so fun, I really enjoy it!
- [Mark] What is so fun
about living on the street?
- [Rebecca] I feel perfect. Look at this.
I found this laying on the
floor. (speaks faintly)
I was very fortunate.
I was given two jewelers,
got a cigar, smoked it.
Sing some Beyonce, and then
I kind of do some modeling.
I thought I saw a genuine
Furstenberg, (indistinct)
'cause then I reached (indistinct)
and also I'm a homeless person
who would probably be
like (speaks faintly).
- [Mark] So what will
you do later tonight,
Saturday night?
- Look for dresses in the dumpster.
Find somebody to listen to music, party.
Probably look a house for Varunshaw and-or
(hands slapping)
whatever the fuck it is
that I end up doing.
- Whatever comes up.
- Whatever is the funnest thing, you know.
I always feel like the
best, know what I mean?
You know, there's a quote
by my favorite, favorite,
favorite, favorite fashion
editor, Henrice Andaluz.
She goes, "You know, and all these young,
"all the kids, they wanna go
"to the store today and buy jeans.
"I'm like, hey ladies, why
you wanna go buy jeans?
"Let's go buy a Versace jacket."
That's kind of the attitude
I have, you know what I mean?
I don't wanna wear a t-shirt and shorts
and go work at fucking,
you know, Starbucks,
or even maybe aspire to
be a hostess at Zanque.
I'd literally rather,
you know what I mean,
be digging through those
street (indistinct).
I not gonna spend 10
hours of my fucking life,
be like, yeah, the work, the grind,
and then go home and be like,
fuck it, and watch "Melrose
Place," and it's like,
but Melrose Place is right over there.
Why watch reruns of "Melrose Place?"
Ever wanna meet Lisa Rinna?
She's incredible.
(Mark laughing)
- [Mark] Can't say you're not fun.
- Huh?
- I can't say you're not fun.
- That's very sweet of you to say.
Thank you for that.
I can't say you're not really like,
there's like warm about
you, warmth kind of.
- Oh, thank you.
- A really warm vibe.
- Cool.
- [Mark] Well, Rebecca,
thank you so much for coming by again.
- [Rebecca] Thank you so much-
- [Mark] It was a nice
surprise to see you.
- [Rebecca] It definitely is.
I just, I happened to run into you, right.
- [Mark] Every time I
see Repeat, I see Rebecca
at the same time.
This is the second time you
guys showed up together.
(laughs) I'm starting to-
- Me and who, you said?
- [Mark] The gentlemen I
was speaking to outside was-
- I've I've never actually
seen him anywhere else
other than in that
instance, that's really-
- [Mark] His street name is Repeat.
- You know, you kinda
remind me in an irony.
It's like the inverse.
Have you ever heard of that movie "Blah,"
Michelangelo Antonioni?
- I don't.
- You're kind of like an inverse of that.
- [Mark] Just don't say
Matthew McConaughey.
Not that there's anything wrong with-
- You're like Matthew McConaughey
mixed with Sarah Jessica Parker.
- [Mark] I've heard
Matthew McConaughey a lot.
Rebecca, thank you so much.
- Thank you so much.
- You're delightful.
- You are beautiful.
- [Mark] (laughs) You are, too.
- Thank you.